let's talk about it with editor-in-chief
of The Daily wire Ben Shapiro Ben
welcome great to have you I know that
you've raised some concerns or at least
pointed out that this potentially does
not line up with some of her political
leanings yeah I mean I'm very sick of
politicians just generally claiming that
some sort of heritage allows them to get
off the hook for their current political
positions I've never heard anything
about Ocasio cortezes Jewish heritage
before this we've seen politicians like
Hillary Clinton John Kerry do the same
thing talking about their Jewish
heritage that they don't actually have
to talk about their policies with regard
to Jews Ocasio Cortez is incredibly
close to people like Linda Sarsour and
rashida talaiya but no hon Omar and
she's not shy with about associating
with folks who are fans of the
anti-semitic boycotts best in sanctions
regimes so again it's it's an easy way
of avoiding the question but it has
about as much political weight as
somebody being accused of racism and
then saying well I once had a black
friend well it's interesting you bring
up BDS and you brought that up in a
tweet today because she was asked her
her spokesperson was asked about it on
Friday and kind of gave no comment on it
and where she potentially stands on it
but you'll have lit been retweeted what
you had said and said this there's no
doubt Ben Shapiro is the quintessential
quote Uncle Tom of Jews in his mind
endorsing BDS somehow outweighs being
Jewish pour Shapiro he was skillfully
shut down by Acacio and still feels sore
over its yeah well I mean this is the
usual line is if you criticize our cosby
of cortez in any way this is because you
were obsessed with Ocasio cortez again
here's the reality if you are in favor
of boycotts boycotting divesting and
sanctioning the Jewish state but you're
fine with everything the Palestinians
are doing the Iranians are doing the
Saudis are doing the Yemenis are doing
the Afghani ZAR doing or any other
country in the region that has no human
rights to speak of but you're somehow
going to boycott Israel because
somebody's building an extra bathroom in
Jewish East Jerusalem then suddenly
that's that's not anti-semitic of course
the census medic by definition I mean
this is the State Department says if you
are to treat Israel in a way you would
treat no other state then this is the
definition of anti-semitism
BDS is anti-semitism and Ocasio Cortez
has not disassociated from anyone who
has associated with with BDS or radical
anti-israel activity I know at one point
you offered up I think it was $10,000
that you would donate to charity for her
to come and debate you any response on
that
no it wasn't just debating me but it was
all so she could come and just do an
interview on my show and I said that you
know we can do it for no pay I mean um
but this was this was considered
catcalling she accused me of catcalling
I mean has she looked at me I'm not
exactly a cat caller the Orthodox
Judaism sort of prohibits that it does
okay so keep us up to date if anything
developments on that front I also want
to ask you about the fact that you've
been named as the keynote speaker for
the March for life it is something that
we've covered for years I've been out
there many times myself
come snowstorm or sleet or anything else
that's happening in January there are
thousands and thousands of people who
come here to March commemorating roe v--
wade they are pro-life in nature tell us
how you came about being associated with
them and what message you hope to bring
this year well I mean the March for Life
is an amazing event I've been watching
it for years and I never had a chance to
attend when they came to me and offered
a keynote slot at the March for life I
thought what better way to bring
attention to the most pressing social
issue in America and of the time it is
the moral issue upon which all Americans
will be judged I think not only in this
life but but in another and future
generations are gonna look back and
wonder how it is that so many Americans
stood by and basically shrugged their
shoulders as babies in the womb were
killed for the sake of convenience so I
couldn't be more excited about standing
with the folks who are marching for life
and standing with the unborn what I
asked you if you were surprised at all
that you got some pushback in the
washington post an article by charles
chemisty he's professor and he's a board
member of democrats for life he says
despite suit Shapiro's star power in
stature i consider his appearance a
serious mistake for the march one that
will move us even further from being
understood as the broad-based human
rights movement we need to embody in
order to go from fringe to mainstream he
tweeted this
hey March for life who will be featured
this year to represent the millions and
millions of pro lifers who don't
identify as politically conservative I
mean again I'm more than happy and I
wish that there were more Democrats who
identified as pro-life but the question
here is not whether it's a conservative
or leftist issue the real question here
is whether it is indeed about the unborn
children and that's why whatever I've
said about abortion has no relevance to
Democrat a Republican other than the
Democratic Party has become the party of
abortion I wish that more Democrats were
pro-life it is not my fault or the fault
of Republicans that so many Democrats
have
to the pro-life category and into the
radical pro-choice category and
pretending otherwise is not going to
change the facts on the ground well
wherever you are on the spectrum
pro-life - pro-choice it's a really
interesting event that doesn't always
get covered fairly I think here in
Washington so I encourage people to you
know check it out for themselves and
make an objective assessment of what
goes on their bench Bureau great to see
you thanks for coming on good to see you
- thanks so much